good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about five ways to reduce
your stress the first time I came to
United States wherever I went I heard
this term stress management I could not
understand because in my understanding
we manage things which are precious to
us our families our businesses our
mining our property whatever is precious
to us we will manage that why would
somebody want to manage stress I
couldn't get it for something then I
realized people have made a conclusion
that stress is an extra limb that they
have in their body stress is an
appendage that they cannot get rid of
stress is not a part of you you get
stressful because you do not know how to
handle your mind now attention has been
paid as to how to handle this mind how
to handle this emotion how to handle
this body how to handle this energies
nothing has been done about it
you're managing such a sophisticated
system accidentally so you're being
stressful is a natural outcome of such
unconscious living there is no other way
to be don't think your job is stressful
now you're a student being a student is
stressful if you don't find employment
when you come out of the college that is
stressful if you get a job even more
if you don't get married that is very
stressful if you get married I don't
want to say anything you don't have
children that is stressful if you have
children you pull your hair out with
stress so it is not your job or your
life situations which are stressful
stress is happening to you because of
your inability to manage your own system
not knowing how to manage the system is
stressful Ness if this happened the way
you want it you wouldn't be stressful
model Bruce Lee Bruce Lee used to write
out a worry list on a piece of paper
he'd actually dump all of the worries
that were swirling through his mind onto
a piece of paper why because if it's in
your mind if you're worried about all
these problems they will consume your
creativity and they'll consume your
physical energy and your two best assets
are number one your physical focus and
your mental focus and number two your
physical energy I'll repeat that your
two primary assets are your mental focus
and your physical energy as a business
person and as a human being protect
those as we go through the intense
disruption that will continue
so the first tactic is to write all the
worries down on a piece of paper and
then what Bruce Lee used to do is he'd
rip up the piece of paper into many
pieces and they hold the lighter to it
or a match and need to see them burning
up you don't have to do that but it's
just simply powerful to start keeping a
worry list so you sort of dump all the
worries that are consuming your focus
out onto a piece of paper and then guess
what your mind has space for its
creativity to express itself so one of
the best ways to stop worrying and start
living is to take things one day at a
time forget what's happened in the past
that you cannot change and don't worry
about what might happen in the future
99% of the things that you worry about
will never occur you can always use the
worry Buster formula to clear
your mind if there's a problem in your
life that is causing you to worry
remember that most things you worry
about never happen anyway there are four
steps to applying the worry buster to
your situation to help you stop worrying
completely number one define your
problem clearly accurate diagnosis is
half the cure what exactly are you
worrying about write it down if you
possibly can
number two is ask yourself what is the
worst possible outcome of this situation
I call this a white wpo analysis worst
possible outcome some people call it
filling out the disaster report what is
the worst and think about what exactly
could happen if this situation did occur
step number three is resolved to accept
the worst possible outcome should it
occur whatever might happen decide that
you will be able to live with it it
won't kill you take it one day at a time
now you found out how to stop worrying
and finally begin immediately to make
sure that the worst possible outcome
does not occur think of all the creative
things you could do to minimize the
worst possible occurrence pretty soon
you'll be thinking positively and
creatively again and you'll be back in
control of your life no sort of
five-point plan anyone can follow to get
over stress and trauma in their lives
totally through it well I think first of
all I make one thing clear the quality
of your life is the quality of where you
live emotionally but we all have a home
angry people try and find a way to get
angry even if their life doesn't they'd
be angry about we can always find it sad
people find what have you sad caring
people find a way to care for other
people
so one thing gonna identify is where are
you living what's your home what's your
habit and then the way to change it is
when I was homeless literally on my own
just getting started I didn't have the
internet but I have decided I had to go
to a library and I had to feed my mind
and I always tell people the first stage
is you know weeds grow automatically one
of my teachers taught me is that every
day stand guard at the door of your mind
and feed it something good because if
your worst enemy puts sugar in your
coffee here you're fine if your best
friend by accident trying to help you
put some strychnine you're dead so if
you feed your mind every day 30 minutes
a day of reading something hearing
something second you got to strengthen
your body and the reason Pierce is fear
is physical
right so is stagnation so is numbness so
a sadness that so it's rage and when you
going to change your body by an intense
workout or a run or even intense walk
and the Bloods flowing through you
science has shown it instantly changes
your biochemistry now your mind-body
you're working together
third thing all these people did in
common if you watch they found a mission
bigger than themselves yeah something
that they weren't to aspire to that was
worth more than their pain and then the
fourth thing is you got to find a role
model you know you heard it and with
Nick almost anybody finds a role model
that makes it real I was with Warren
Buffett and with Sara Blakely the
youngest billionaire we did this
roundtable about the future and we
listened this woman and when women meet
her
they don't just love Spanx or product
that made her a billionaire they love
this woman because she's a role model
what's possible yeah you get a role
model it becomes real to you if you get
a plan you get a goal plan and you take
massive action and the last step number
five there's always somebody all or
something you are I don't care what
you've done so if you can go help
somebody worse off you'd put your life
in perspective and it also reminds you
life's not about me it's about we I
always tell people the secret to a great
life the secret to living is giving and
there's when you realize there's
something you still to give even if you
lost your legs even if you've been
through a horrific financial situation
your life can improve but more
importantly you'll have a meaningful
life because your life will contribute
to other people stresses the big hidden
ager of all there are a couple of things
that really age us a lot and the stress
is one of the biggest ones and so often
we stress out about our health which is
the exact opposite of what you want to
do and even in pregnancy when women are
all stressed off because they'd be
hurting the baby from having a drink
before they found out they were pregnant
or maybe they just stopped smoking
cigarettes you're more likely to hurt
the child from the stress you're
experiencing then you are from any toxic
event that you engage them the same is
true for your life so how do you deal
with stress well it's not the stress per
se it's the response to stress that's
important so don't quit your job don't
stop working keep doing the things that
give you passion and envision in life
but practice some stress management
techniques one that I like to show
everybody is deep breath so take a deep
breath you don't go like that which is
what most people do so everyone out
there we can do this together on the
count of eight okay you get put your
right hand in your stomach now when you
take a deep breath in the first thing to
do is to push the stomach out that
brings the diaphragm down and gives you
more room for your lungs to open up baby
do this naturally singers do this
athletes do this but we forget to do it
so for in for out ready okay deep breath
in one push your belly button out to
push your way out three four way out way
up now relax to make five exhale six now
push your belly button towards your
spine suck it in
seven eight inhale one two three push
the stomach way up four put a hold of
difference a little ache a little bit up
in here now exhale relax the belly five
six now suck the belly button towards
spine exhale all the air nice t done
that's a deep belly breath it's the
foundation of all yoga which I do every
morning it's the foundation of mystic
Christianity many religions found
foundations support
the fundamentally important aspect
taking deep breath and now is doctors
should we do that deep breath ten times
when you feel stressed uh-huh so in the
course of a minute
you can be sitting in a give me at your
job if Elvises are breathing you want to
strangle the person next to you and it's
a way that's fine morrow I'm good to go
and it works I like that can changing
how you think about stress make you
healthier and here the science says yes
when you change your mind about stress
you can change your body's response to
stress now to explain how this works I
want you all to pretend that you are
participants in a study designed to
stress you out it's called the social
stress test you come into the laboratory
and you're told you have to give a five
minute impromptu speech on your personal
weaknesses to a panel of expert
evaluators sitting right in front of you
and to make sure you feel the pressure
there are bright lights and a camera in
your face kind of like this and the
evaluators have been trained to give you
discouraging nonverbal feedback like
this
now that you're sufficiently demoralized
time for part two a math test
and unbeknownst to you the experimenter
has been trained to harass you during it
now we're gonna all do this together
it's gonna be fun for me okay I want you
all to count backwards from 996 in
increments of seven you're gonna do this
out loud as fast as you can
starting with 996 go go faster faster
please you're going too slow stop stop
stop stop that guy made a mistake we're
gonna have to start all over again
you're not very good at this are you
okay so you get the idea now if you were
actually in this study you'd probably be
a little stressed out your heart might
be pounding you might be breathing fast
or maybe breaking out into a sweat and
normally we interpret these physical
changes as anxiety or signs that we
aren't coping very well with the
pressure but what have you viewed them
instead as signs that your body was
energized was preparing you to meet this
challenge now that is exactly what
participants were told in a study
conducted at Harvard University before
they went through the social stress
tests they were taught to rethink their
stress response as helpful that pounding
heart is preparing you for action if
you're breathing faster it's no problem
it's getting more oxygen to your brain
and participants who learned to view the
stress response as helpful for their
performance well they were less stressed
out less anxious more confident but the
most fascinating finding to me was how
their physical stress response changed
now in a typical stress response your
heart rate goes up and your blood
vessels constrict like this and this is
one of the reasons that chronic stress
is sometimes associated with
cardiovascular disease it's not really
healthy to be in this state all the time
but in the study when participants
viewed their stress response as helpful
their blood vessels stay
relax like this their heart was still
pounding but this is a much healthier
cardiovascular profile it actually looks
a lot like what happens in moments of
joy and courage over a lifetime of
stressful experiences this one
biological change could be the
difference between a stress induced
heart attack at age 50 and living well
into your 90s and this is really what
the new science of stress reveals that
how you think about stress matters so my
goal as a health psychologist has
changed I no longer want to get rid of
your stress I want to make you better at
stress and we just did a little
intervention if you raised your hand and
said you'd had a lot of stress in the
last year we could have saved your life
because hopefully the next time your
heart is pounding from stress you're
going to remember this talk and you're
gonna think to yourself this is my body
helping me rise to this challenge and
when you view stress in that way your
body believes you and your stress
response becomes healthier for you think
how do you reduce your stress I usually
go for a dance class dance class or get
massage massages are good for pedicure
I've been the one pedicure ever yeah my
color I know I cut my nails support
going didn't know that see if someone's
looking at my toes I need to I need the
game there's a pedicure freak out I
didn't know pedicure was cutting it
anyway for me what do I do
you know I try to run a stress-free life
and business with intention
I run what I call it no crisis business
I don't have a cell phone so people can
reach me and I try not to work with
clients who always are dumping things on
me last-minute with intention I try not
to do that to my team too
I try not to last minute I really need
this done tomorrow guys and it really
kills me what I have to do it and I
think that's the first part is that I'm
just trying to not to have stress and I
think it's not repair you can design
your own life and pick your clients and
pick your lifestyle and as much as
possible just try to do that when I am
stressed doesn't happen that often
I can handle a good amount of stress I'm
pretty chill in general I generally need
to breathe breathe I'm just reminding
myself of the bigger picture and I have
to when I'm really stressed I have to be
alone I'm an introvert and I need time
to think and figure it out and then I
have a plane I can be around people
again but I kind of shut down and I go
and I go inwards if I get
yeah
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you have an amazing day I'd love to
know which of the clips that you saw
today meant to most to you had the
biggest impact leaving the comments
below and I'll join in the discussion
and if there's a topic you want Evan
cover and a future believe life video
leave the comments below to eleven thank
you guys for watching each we took the
leave and I'll see you soon
there's no question that at some point
even if you decide not to be a stress
case you actively manage your
perspective about time and importance
you're taking in breath you're still
gonna get it with days where you feel
overwhelmed that there's a lot going on
and you're kind of freaked out about it
so here's two very simple things you can
do one take a walk you know leave the
office or leave your house go for a
little bit of walk you know I'm not
talking about you know walking across
the country and he's like
responsibilities though that sounds cool
I would just say go for a short stroll
you know 20 to 45 minutes of a walk
outside yes outside can completely open
up your mind again help you find calm
and just some kind of inner sense
because you're walking you're moving
you're breathing for some of you that
might mean exercise you know go for a
run go for a jog like move your body to
dispel some of that physical tension and
your mental attention your mental
tension might go with it as well make
sense right and then finally just remove
stress it's so simple you're gonna hate
it it's so tactical and people hate when
I say this but it's time to get
organized most of the stress that is in
our lives can be managed if we just
organized said okay I'm gonna deal with
this on this day this on this day this
on this day if we really chunked out the
hours of the day to move towards
accomplishing the things that are
troubling us you know sometimes just
knowing that tomorrow you're gonna
handle it from 9:00 a.m. till 10:00 a.m.
it creates peace of mind it like moves
it off the stress of now to saying
that's the time this is going to be
handled and once you have this knowledge
in mind that's what I'm gonna handle it
it releases a little bit of that
craziness that's going on right now